[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation tous les jours dans les
médias
nous entendons des accusations de
complotisme contre ceux qui n'adhèrent
pas la pensée convenue en contrepoint
ceux qui les accusent même des actions
d' influence pour obliger la majorité
des citoyens à adhérer à leur point de
vue ainsi dans le débat d'idées c'est
créer une barrière infranchissable
opposant les défenseurs du bien commun
et les thuriféraires du malade ce les
conséquences en sont graves puisque en
contradiction avec les principes mêmes
de la démocratie
il s'agit d'interdire la liberté de
penser autrement sous peine d'exclusion
l'amendement numéro 1 de la constitution
des états unis stipule que le congrès
n'adoptera aucune loi relative à
l'établissement d'une religion ou à
l'interdiction de son libre exercice ou
pour limiter l'expression de la presse
ou le droit des citoyens de se réunir
pacifiquement et d'adresser au
gouvernement des pétitions pour obtenir
réparation des torts subis
l'article 19 de la constitution
française affirme que tout individu a
droit à la liberté d'opinion et
d'expression ce qui implique le droit de
ne pas être inquiété pour ses opinions
et celui de chercher de recevoir et de
répandre les informations et les idées
sans considération de frontières par
quelque moyen d'expression que ce soit
on en est loin
quand on voit aux états unis et en
france
certains médias et administrations sous
la pression de groupes minoritaires
puissant rejeter ou interdire de parole
des associations des partis ou des
porteurs d'idées dont le tort est de
refuser la tyrannie de la bien pensante
pourtant c'est du débat qu'on s'enrichit
de nos différences et connaît la
solution constructive qui peut être
partagé en vérité l'accusation de
complotisme est de plus en plus employée
par des gens qui ignorent ce que le mot
veut dire la définition du larousse
précise qu'on emploie ce mot pour
désigner quelqu'un ou un groupe qui
réfutent la version communément admise
d'un événement et cherche à démontrer
que celui ci résulte d'un complot mené
par une minorité active dans l'histoire
le complotisme repose généralement sur
une interprétation qui peut aller dans
ses excès jusqu'à la négation de la
réalité historique dans un sens ou dans
un autre
alimenté par des fake news fausse
partiellement fausses ou des infos
vraies qui aurait dû rester secrète
il peut délibérément devenir actions d'
influence quand il est exercé par le
camp de la bien pensante
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire on en a
aujourd'hui un exemple intéressant avec
le mythe de l'homme blanc responsable de
tous les maux subis par l'humanité chant
creuse plus on découvre qu'une partie
des élites se sentant menacé ali le
complotisme au populisme dans un mépris
de l'expression du peuple devenu censé
ne pas pouvoir comprendre la réalité du
monde
cette ambiguïté explique que face aux
théories complotistes des intellectuels
soit régulièrement tiraillé entre des
convictions
catégoriquement opposé ce que pierre
bayard appelle les croyances
intermédiaire
provoquant une levée de boucliers la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur a
dénoncé il ya quelques jours l'existence
d'un islamo gauchistes qui s'est
développée depuis longtemps à tous les
niveaux de responsabilité dans les
universités et la recherche dans un pays
de liberté comme la france ils ont le
droit qu'on ne peut leur ôter d'avoir
leurs idées même si elle soit que
certains mais interdiction doit leur
être faite de les imposer en exerçant
des pressions sur ceux qui n'y adhèrent
pas
c'est pareil pour les partisans de
l'écriture inclusive
comme on l'a vu récemment à sciences po
ce n'est pas à eux d'imposer une
nouvelle façon d'écrire le français car
seule la loi peut le faire et ils
doivent la respecter
ne serait ce que sur le plan éthique
hank enseignants et fonctionnaires de
l'état
de la même façon n'importe quel groupe
ou regroupement d'hommes et de femmes de
n'importe quelle tendance de gauche ou
de droite d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême
droite a le droit dans notre pays de
revendiquer de faire connaître ses idées
s'ils respectent strictement les lois de
la république d'un citoyen peut
s'exprimer sur les réseaux sociaux et ne
pas être censuré pour avoir dit ce qu'il
pense sous sa propre identité
à partir du moment où les termes
employés
même s'il déplaise n'enfreignent pas la
loi
une femme a le droit de porter le voile
dans l'espace public
dans le cas de sa religion à partir du
moment comme tous les français où son
visage est découvert en permanence pour
permettre son identification
quand l'état et les citoyens de des
formes plus les valeurs fondamentales
graver dans la constitution
il laisse le champ libre au militantisme
identitaire des minorités de tous bords
attention de ne pas quitter les rives de
la démocratie pour entrer dans les
tourbillons de la démocrature avaient
tous et néfastes conséquences
attention à une dictature molle dans
laquelle les dirigeants ne défendent
plus les principes républicains
ballotté au gré du bruit médiatique
construit par des groupes qui
considèrent leurs idées comme les seuils
acceptables et à cliquable à tous il
remplace le courage du guide créateur
d'espérance par la démagogie du suiveur
qui s'adapte au fil du temps présent
est il normal que dans une démocratie au
nom de leur politique morale et de leur
interprétation de nos lois nationales
facebook ou twitter puis censuré des
textes et des comptes ouverts chez eux
ce d'autant plus aberrant que ces
sociétés étrangères en le faisant ne
respecte pas l'amendement numéro un de
leur propre état que des élus de notre
république
et puis voté la transmission de ce qui
relève du régalien à des entreprises
privées
de surcroît étrangères montre bien la
déliquescence d'un système qui n'a plus
la volonté d'utiliser son administration
pour faire respecter des lois
heureusement le conseil constitutionnel
a réagi mais combien temps pourra-t-il
le faire face aux actions d' influence
de ceux qui cherchent à le déstabiliser
peut-on parler de complotisme quand les
états veulent faire croire alors
concitoyens des vérités qui n'en sont
pas souvenons nous en 2020 de la
ministre de la santé
relayé par tous les cadres supérieurs de
son administration affirmant que les
masques étaient inutiles elles ne
voulaient pas ou ne pouvez pas
reconnaître que ses prédécesseurs
n'avaient pas reconstituer le stock
nécessaire pour des raisons bassement
financières
quand les américains pour justifier la
future guerre en irak et frappé les
esprits ont argué que saddam hussein
allait avoir la bombe atomique alors
même que tous les spécialistes avec
c'était fou ils ont médiatisé une fac
news
c'est ainsi qu'une partie non
négligeable de l'amérique profonde croit
encore à ce mensonge nucléaire quand les
chinois nous assurent qu'ils n'ont eu
que 4636 mort du covin en chine
peut-on sérieusement les croire le
problème est que la puissance de l'
influence de l'état un pacte la plupart
de ceux qui écoutent
alors certes parodiant charles pasqua
on pourrait dire cyniquement que ce type
d'information n'engagent que ceux qui
les entendent
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que le
problème futur sera celui de la
crédibilité des messages émis par un
état
rattrapé par ses mensonges alors il est
vrai que l'être humain oublie vite
mais les mensonges d'état sont du pain
béni pour alimenter les théories du
complot
dans quel domaine peut-on classe et la
négation de l'histoire
ou plus exactement sa lecture partielle
et partiale qui on supprime des pans
entiers parce qu'ils ne correspondent
pas au sens qu'on veut lui donner
l'histoire de l'afrique vue par les
blacks live matters et leurs homologues
français montrent une méconnaissance
absolue de ce qui s'est passé est une
volonté d'ignorer l'ensemble des acteurs
nous sommes dans le complotisme quand on
charge un bouc émissaire de toute la
responsabilité de cette horreur pourquoi
ne pas reconnaître que des chefs de
tribus africaines vendaient leurs
prisonniers et prisonnières aux
marchands arabes qui eux mêmes les
revendait aux bateaux négriers
sur la côte ouest de l'afrique et dans
la péninsule arabique et cela jusqu'au
xxème siècle personne ne peut nier que
légalement
l'esclavagé a été aboli je ne sais pas
si vous le savez en arabie saoudite en
1962 à oman au sultanat doman en 1970 et
en mauritanie
en 1980 alors que la france le fit en
1794 puis définitivement en 1848
comme le rappelle et de noailles qu il
faut respecter les faits avoir une
interprétation et des explications
cohérentes pour être réellement crédible
vouloir forcer le destin en récrivant
une histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater il
n'y a pas de recette anti fait qu news
d'autant qu'elles sont utilisées par
tous les acteurs le maniement de la
rumeur si bien expliqué par jean noël
kapferer est vieux comme le monde mais
il est vrai que l'arrivée des réseaux
sociaux a multiplié son impact et il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité
pour identifier ces faits que new
certains grands quotidiens français ont
mis en place des outils de détection qui
donne l'alertent le problème tient au
fait qu'ils ont des processus de
sélection qui ne s'intéressent qu'aux
messages allant contre leur camp
manifestant ainsi une curieuse absence
de sensibilité sur tout ce qui pourrait
les gêner
il est vrai qu'au-delà du recoupement
d'informations pour en valider la
crédibilité
il faut avoir une connaissance fine de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
il ne suffit pas d'extraire des listes
d'influenceurs souvent interdépendants
des groupes d'activistes ou certaines
ong dans lesquelles la manipulation de
l'information fait partie de leur adn
pour être sécurisé il faut aussi
comprendre et suivre leurs échanges et
leurs agissements sur le web et les
réseaux sociaux et nous savons très bien
qu'ils peuvent se rendre service en
utilisant mutuellement leurs réseaux
personnels pour lancer des messages afin
d'en cacher la véritable origine les
galaxies société et d'associations
philanthropiques ou humanitaires
financés par certains grands opérateurs
financiers ou industriels d'ailleurs en
donne d'excellents exemples françois
bernard huyghe qui flottent un des rares
précurseur dans l'étude de l' influence
la définit comme une stratégie indirecte
visant à obtenir d'autrui un assentiment
ou un comportement soit par le précise
son image soit par une forme quelconque
de persuasion et de formatage des
critères de jugement soit enfin
d'ailleurs par la médiation d'alliés de
réseau en définitive
c'est le moyen d'amener celui auquel on
s'adresse envisager une autre vision des
choses à changer son paradigme de penser
et à modifier ses fondamentaux
on y arrive par le biais des éléments
qu'on lui présente et qu'il invite à
réfléchir
et alors un constat s'impose plus on est
intelligent et plus on est théoriquement
influençable parce que l' influence fait
appel à la capacité d analyse l'auditeur
celui ci doit faire le tri entre ce
qu'il pense habituellement et les
éléments nouveaux qui lui sont soumis et
dont il lui appartient de mesurer la
validité tout argument solide qui lui
est proposée peut ainsi le conduire à
revoir son jugement et donc son
positionnement
c'est ce qu'explique comme l'écrivait
déjà dans une tribune jacques marceau de
la fondation concorde en 2019
le rapide développement de ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence relationnelle
dans les très grandes entreprises
mondiales comme moteur de leur stratégie
de conquête
il repose sur un réseau relationnel
structure et incluant chacune des
parties prenantes à l'aide de puissants
réseaux de communication et d influence
on constate d'ailleurs l'absence presque
totale de publicités dans les grands
médias
mais une omniprésence des représentants
de ces groupes dans les lieux de pouvoir
à la commission à bruxelles ou à paris
ainsi il retrouvait met en oeuvre un
principe connu depuis fort longtemps la
qualité des échanges entre les individus
les entreprises et les états doivent
être fondées sur des relations de
confiance réciproque
prenez par exemple bill gates et son
réseau relationnel avec les dirigeants
européens
il met en avant ses actions humanitaires
parlent du futur est quasiment jamais de
ses affaires peut-être est-il
sincèrement soucieux du bien d'autrui
en tout cas cela ressemble à s'y
méprendre à l'application méthodique
d'une stratégie d' influence un autre
bon exemple est donné par elon musk le
patron de tesla et de spe 6 il s'est
forgé une image dans laquelle les
résultats de l'entreprise ne sont rien
par rapport à la dynamique qui émane de
ses projets de lui même et qui fascine
ses interlocuteurs nous sommes moins les
campagnes publicitaires et des comptes
rendus aux analystes financiers
au niveau international en quelques
années l'un peu lens a pris toute sa
place au coeur des affrontements
politiques et économiques internationaux
car elle est une manifestation de la
puissance capable de peser sur
l'évolution des situations
le président trump avait poussé les
actions d'influencé à la caricature avec
ces menaces et affirmations sa
rhétorique guerrière et sa multitude de
tweets pour impressionner l'adversaire
et l'amener à céder mais nous devons
reconnaître que dans certains cas ceci a
bien fonctionné dans le même ordre
d'idée
regardons la manière dont le président
chinois des poissons programme de
développement des routes de la soie en
amenant les populations concernées leurs
dirigeants à considérer l'arrivée de la
chine comme une véritable opportunité
dans ces domaines très différents
l'autre is hot de queiroz dans une
interview de juillet 2020 nous inviter à
constater que l'art moderne perçu comme
un produit financier par la plupart
d'entre nous est en réalité devenu un
outil d influence
l'amérique utilise l'art contemporain
pour légitimer idéologiquement le
multiculturalisme
ainsi les grands opérateurs pratique en
les adaptant les techniques d influence
utilisé jusqu'ici par les minorités
agissantes pour attirer l'attention des
relais d'opinion et toutes les parties
concernées tous utilisés message
récurrent qui affirme leur identité leur
valeur et leur positionnement en
n'hésitant pas à s'inscrire dans
l'actualité du moment
l'objectif est construire
progressivement une image d'organisation
responsable qui devient naturellement un
interlocuteur privilégié de leurs cibles
dont les premières sont les états
sans agresser elles deviennent en
quelques étapes la référence dans leur
segment de marché
c'est pourquoi dans la communication
d'influencé on privilégie les grilles et
l'information de qualité pour affirmer
son identité
en s'appuyant sur des vecteurs prouvant
l'authenticité de la démarche
c'est ainsi qu'on met en oeuvre une
influence authentique organisé et
structuré
c'est évidemment très différent de la
stratégie de l'anathème et de
l'exclusion pratiqué par des minorités
qui refuse la discussion et le partage
et ne veulent surtout pas comprendre
qu'au delà du bien et du mal
théorique mystique ou révolutionnaire la
vérité réside parmi les tenues ans
intermédiaire apôtres du complotisme à
rebours elles ont peu d'arguments
sérieux à poser à la réalité des faits
en réponse aux attentes des différents
publics
elbaz leurs revendications sur une
médiatisation extrême et tendancieuses
qui agresse mais ne résout rien nous
sommes loin de la stratégie une
influence qui doit s'enclencher à partir
d'un discours cohérent et porteur de
sens
n'oublions pas qu'elle repose sur la
puissance de l'esprit critique et
qu'elle favorise la confrontation par
libre jeu des idées sans chercher à
imposer une vision monolithique
gardons toujours à l'esprit que
l'influencé est avant tout un fluide qui
glisse à travers des canaux
quelle que soit la nature de ces
derniers c'est un rayonnement un contenu
plus qu'un contenant
comme l'a écrit justement bruno
racouchot fondateur de communication et
influences qui fut la première et
pendant longtemps la seule lettre
traitant en france du sujet face aux
accusations de complotisme par certains
ou d' influence dévoyé par d'autres il
faut retrouver nos fondamentaux et
sortir d'un piège dont personne ne peut
sortir gagnant dans la durée avec ernst
young heures souvenons nous que les
états privilégiant le règne paralysant
de la pensée convenue se mue
insensiblement en systèmes totalitaires
il faut donc faire confiance à l'homme
et changer de perspective nous devons
nous éloigner des contraintes du
principe de précaution et de cette
mortelle unicité intellectuelle en
réapprenant à penser autrement
à bientôt
[Musique]